c'est en panique et c'est de là où
utiliser ils vont me tuer n'est ce pas
possible pas pourquoi ils font tout ça
enfin s'est rien passé de particulier
pour qu'il soit aussi violent il ya un
agent et qui se présente à moi ils
pensaient avoir affaire à quelqu'un qui
avait fait un délit ou je sais pas je
demandé s'ils pouvaient être discret
dans sa façon de procéder parce qu'il
était dur dans ses gestes et puis voilà
je voulais pas que s'apprête à un
scandale pour lui ça signifie que je me
laissais pas faire alors que non soit
j'ai pas refusé le contrôle j'ai pas
vous fier d'obtempérer
regardez comment donc il a décidé de me
mettre au sol vous écraser la tête c'est
la gorge le torse levante et ensuite
j'ai senti une pression entre légende et
il y en a un des deux qui tenteront de
m'écraser les parties intimes est que le
pied j'ai commencé à hurler parce que ça
me faisait mal et puis je demandais
aussi aux gens qui étaient autour de
films et quatre maîtres de vous regarder
comment vous le prenez vous voulez quoi
moi ça me met debout ils me contactent
laquelle voiture est ici apprennent la
plante dans le clan ensuite il m'emmène
à côté de la voiture et moi j'essaye de
leur expliquer un certain nombre de
choses j'essaie de parler avec eux
policiers on n'est pas des méchants
pour l'instant là c'est vous les
méchants et en a un qui voulait rien
savoir et la peur du patience
mais d'écraser la tête c'est pas ça elle
a glissé sa main entre mes jambes et il
a appuyé sur les parties intimes
mes couilles mes couilles tu t'y mets
dans la voiture et quand tu me mets dans
la voiture il a une main à l'extérieur
et avec son ordinateur ils firent la
barre d'un cran et tout ce qui peut
prendre faire mal
ça les gens ne le voient pas quand ils
m'ont contrôle est ce parce que je
correspondais un profil le profil de
quelqu'un qui avait fait quelque chose
de mal
du coup les gens qui sont assimilés à ça
bon les traits d'une certaine manière
les traitements ils sont différenciés ça
se résume pas qu'aux minorités
parce que je remarque c'est que tous les
gens et qu'il arrive ce genre de choses
c'est pas les personnes qui sont au plus
haut de de l'ascenseur social
mais le sentiment d'injustice un truc
qui ronge
c'est un truc qui qui fait mal mais
qu'on n'arrive pas à oublier parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à se l'expliquer et du coup
moi c'est ça que je voudrais des
explications - attrapé en septembre en
juin 2019
vous n'avez rien fait du coup je leur
demande des comptes
on est en juin 2020 est toujours pas de
date de procès donc moi c'est trop lent
en policier va enfin en tout cas ceux
qui m'ont attrapé peuvent attraper par
les parties intimes peuvent me les
écraser peuvent me planter avec leurs
clés de voiture c'est pas si grave que
ça
bah si c'était grave la justice elle
aurait été plus rapide que ça je pense
donc une certaine forme de passivité qui
laisse perplexe sont vifs